okay so rich tell me this right so let's
say you've got a woman who's who's had a
high Notch count and she's she's been
with multiple men and she decides she
wants to change and uh settle down and
she she doesn't want to live that life
anymore what does she what does she do
you can't you can't take away the fact
that that exists from her past a smart
woman would hide that from her past
she's not going to overtly
you know walk around with a t-shirt that
says hey guys I've slept with 50 men and
here's all their names sort of thing
um that that would be an incredibly
stupid choice for a woman to make to
broadcast that information unfortunately
though women do that kind of by osmosis
by their digital footprint
um I've talked about this in some videos
before but there's this trend now on
social media I mean you'll see it on
Tick Tock there's a video that I've done
on my YouTube channel last couple months
where this mid 30 year old woman I think
she was in Tulum at the time and she's
breaking down her date with a guy and
why she's no longer seeing him basically
she's saying you know I spent you know
four or five dates with him uh we slept
together and then he kind of ghosted me
and went away and I don't know why and
men are children but I'll find my true
love sort of thing so
the point here is that women do leave a
digital footprint it would be
or it should be encouraged that fathers
and mothers have the conversation with
their daughters that is your value is
based on your beauty and your Purity it
always has been it's been that way
throughout history you can drink as much
Kool-Aid on the toxic feminism lies you
want it's simply not true a high value
virtuous successful man that knows what
his worth is will every single day of
the week choose a Pure Clean woman over
a woman that's been with a whole bunch
of guys in party through her 20s saying
that I've gotten right with God and that
I want you to look past me past my past
is what beta males fall for that's what
the plugged in guys fall for
I mean what's the dangers of that
well setting aside the fact that there's
a higher probability that she'll be a
single mom there's a higher probability
that she's had abortions there's a
higher probability that she's got mental
disorders these are all facts they've
been proven in studies
once you set that aside one of the
biggest problems for guys is when they
get involved into a marriage with a
woman that's been with a lot of guys the
probabilities of her forming a healthy
parabond to him throughout the marriage
and staying married to him happily is
dramatically lower
um there's lots of data published on
this I think the teachman study would be
the main one you guys can look that up
but essentially a virgin is a far better
choice than a woman that slept with 11
guys
okay so so rich I was I was thinking
about which way I take this conversation
was two questions I was going to ask you
but just based on what you said I'm
going to ask you my next question which
I've got here right now I'm a Muslim
okay and there is a a philosopher who
was quite prominent in the 11th and 12th
century his name was Al ghazali he was
one of the early contributors to when
Islam was in its golden age
and um he in his book he states there
are eight qualities which render a
conjural life happy and which must be
sought in the woman in order to assure
the perpetuity of the marriage
piety good character Beauty a small
Dowry ability to Bear children virginity
good lineage and she should not be a
close relative
that makes sense it's a that's a very
reasonable list
it's interesting because
now okay so let me let me ask you the
second question right on just on the
back of that right if this is what is
prescribed to be a high value woman
which is gonna obviously you know the
whole idea of this is that you know if
you marry a woman with these sorts of
intangibles then you're going to have
more chance of success of a successful
marriage and then the children that you
bear in the family that you raise you
know is going to be a success
but what about men all right why do
these same elements not you know why are
they not prescribed to men they haven't
been in history that's just a fact right
they haven't been prescribed in any
culture to men but why is that the case
well men and women are different aren't
they and I think that's one of the areas
that culture and Society gets wrong
terribly today is that they is they as
they try to blur the lines as much as
possible they say men and women are
equal men and women are exactly the same
whatever a man can do a woman can do and
for some areas of life that's true uh a
man can drive a car from point A to
point B and so can a woman
the man will probably park the car
better at point B than the woman will
and that's just that's just a reality of
life you know there's certain things
that men and women are better at women
are better at empathy women are far
better at love and sympathy for you know
things they're more agreeable than men
are you know men are stronger you know
we've got uh a third or maybe 50 percent
more upper body strength than women do
uh so we have strengths and weaknesses
and I don't know why society and culture
keeps trying to perpetrate this lie that
we're exactly the same when we're not
and one of the things that differs for
men is uh they can get away with
sleeping with multiple women and still
fall in love with a woman commit to her
for life and raise a happy healthy
family just fine but the same is not
true for women promiscuity and sexual
partners play a completely different
role in a woman's life than a man does
in fact I mean if you were to tell a
woman well he slept with 20 guys
she probably won't care in fact it's
desirable when you survey a lot of women
that they want a guy with some
experience because there's some social
proof there there there's some
pre-selection that 20 other women wanted
to be with him it's one of the reasons
why you know there's this funny joke out
there that like that um a woman today
would rather date or sleep with a
married man than be with a loser that
lives in his mom's basement because the
married guy has pre-selection right
another woman has chosen him he has
resources that he can distribute and
share which is why you know you get
these phenomenons that actually happen
it's interesting though isn't it it's a
good question I think I'll tell you my
take on this honestly speaking right
I'll give you my opinion on this I think
that you know when you have a a
relationship you have one relationship a
second and a third and a fourth right as
soon as you get to the fourth fifth and
you start div and you start building on
it whether it's a woman or a man my
opinion is right you carry baggage from
one to the other you do okay and why
what happens is you may be involved in a
relationship whether it's male or female
where you have trauma in that
relationship and that trauma can carry
over to the later part of your life and
then by the time you get with somebody
whether you are male or female if you've
had a high and I don't think it's so
much solely about the notch count I
think it's about the mental implication
as well that you have so if you've had
you know if you have a person who's had
10 relationships 15 relationships
long-term ones with damage and you know
in their relationships and that person
is in their 30s or 40s a woman or a male
I think you're gonna you know the the
person who gets with that individual is
gonna have to deal with a lot of
problems and Trauma yeah I think you're
right about the baggage part and that
and that definitely applies to women
I've noticed women that have been with a
lot of guys have a lot more baggage
there's more of he hurt me he cheated on
me he did whatever to me and they never
really seemed to
like sust through that they never seem
to work that out
I think men do carry baggage too
um you know we all have been betrayed in
our past you know women have done things
that uh have surprises have shocked us
it's one of the things that sends men
down the rabbit hole the red pill and
you know like the concepts that I talk
about in my book and a lot of my videos
is they find it because they've been
betrayed because they believed in
something that wasn't a reality that
they're then shown a truth or reality
that's very uncomfortable it's difficult
even painful for a lot of men and they
have to confront it
um men need to confront these realities
so I think guys that have that have done
the work and they've confronted it they
come out better for it but yeah you're
right men and women do carry baggage
it's just I see men dealing with the
baggage better than women women seem to
just carry it around and it never really
seems to go away for them
interesting because this is this is what
I this is where I kind of stand with
this is that I think that so a lot of
the issues that you talk about when When
selecting um a good woman I believe that
a lot of them qualities but then you
have additional qualities also apply to
men but the difference is is that when a
woman selects a man she needs that man
to be a high value man in terms of his
career as well and I don't think that
applies necessarily this in the opposite
direction but there are definitely
crossovers between the two yeah because
I mean the biggest difference is that
men are viewed as success objects by
women so they're not counting doesn't
really matter as long as they're
successful they're competent they can
make it rain they're they're strong
they're virtuous you know they can look
up to the guy that's that's what's most
important to to to women whereas for men
women are are Beauty objects so a lot of
what women do today to try to make
themselves more attractive to men like
you'll see them online and they'll brag
about their degrees and how smart they
are and they have their own house and
they have their own car well what
they're defining is what met is what
makes men attractive and they think that
if they behave and they act like men
that they will be more attractive to men
but there's no man ever throughout
history that's ever looked at a woman's
degree on a wall framed in Mahogany with
little letters after a name that said oh
yeah look at the degree on her that's
hot they're looking at her walking away
in her nice yoga pants
that's just that's just the reality
that's just the reality I could sit here
and say whatever I want but that is that
that is that is the facts that's true I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out